this is Doritos and Breyers
speaking of Bree can you get the special
thing for us well I can only guess what
this is oh you did you mix them together
oh Christ
oh it's exactly what you think it is
actually I love how you said Doritos
considering it's actually Doritos it's a
Breyers to just say no I just say yeah I
surprisingly was not at your ice cream I
was alone the mood for you seemed like
your chips I think chocolate chips
though hmm are you eating it with the
chips though are you separating the two
I'm supposed to have both together have
a them together as an abomination and
they're going to hell for it well I'm
already going to hell anyways so it's
the chips and ice cream oh god it's that
good huh you know when I was a kid and I
watched a ninja turtles I always wanted
to try those Pizza combination you know
I wanted to do that as like videos and
whatnot
it's know like episode by episode and
whatever topping they'd have I'd
actually make that P James Rolfe
actually all that jerk yeah he is kinda
one of them actually was okay he said
all the others were terrible but I once
it was like marshmallow and pizza or
something like that like there's one
that was actually alright but yeah the
rest were apparently really nasty so
okay this is an episode where this I'm
good though to hop is it that yeah
that's that's amazing but what am I
I was gonna take it away oh no I want
the actual ice cream the ice cream I eat
all my leaves the chips still in there
well I mean where am I gonna play guess
I kept omen
so pretty much what it is is that this
bear has these two these two little
creatures eyes head that just say champs
and ice cream and he does a little
puppet show with them and beemo loves it
all these little kids love it and so
they invited him over to dinner and he
over the moonlight transfers the little
creatures onto Jake's head Jake's just
mildly annoyed he's actually not
horrified yet you know he's just kind of
kind of a nuisance but obviously he has
a hand of my his head as long as this
other guy has and BMO tries to translate
and figure it out but the bear finds he
has Stockholm Syndrome to these things
and tries to um you know to tries to go
back and he tries to get him back on his
head but BMO figures out the language
and can apparently speak it very well
and goes to free them the bear comes you
want to back on there but BMO captures
on that then lets them go free and the
bear is happy that they're free and then
they kind of reenact the opening right
because doesn't fly by and they kiss
them and stuff like that so and they
seem to be happy so that you know it's
so funny because like just before this
we were talking about like Andy Kaufman
like at stand-ups and how much it is
just kind of like almost instinctual
silly or whatever just what you're not
expecting and stuff and here's this
episode starts off with these two things
just saying chips and ice cream and the
kids laughing and going nuts and BMO
loves and everything and we have a
brought up Andy Kaufman man eating ice
cream like we brought that up I'm like
this is really quite a coincidence
so yeah it's uh ice cream that's all I
can say about it I mean it's it's okay I
think the idea of him like wanting to
get away and then find me he can't live
without him that's kind of funny
yeah and interesting um especially the
soccer versions yeah the funny thing is
when they sang chips and ice cream
uh I was count compared to Einstein on
the beach which is usually not a good
comparison but but in this case like it
actually almost kind of sounded nice you
know it's kind of like this it's this
weird gibberish and some it's kind of
spoken some of it's sung but together
almost kind of worked a kind of actually
sound very nice listening to it um let's
also cathing going to because it's just
saying those two words over and over and
I like the way those two could talk and
you could tell that they were saying
something even though it was just
technically chips and ice cream but they
were actually communicating so I mean
that was okay well okay so chips and ice
cream are the duo Garfunkel and Oates
yeah what is what why do I know I'm
Haiti I can never say her last name
she is Sadie from Steven universe from
the ah yes we get all excited so second
episode in a row it's a Steven universe
more like half the people from like
Steven universe and this and like
gravity falls like they're all just
connected in one way or another well I
know that gravity falls and Rick and
Morty are really close now that's
insurance like they're like the creators
like best friends I found that out which
i think is they're like almost polar
opposite shows okay kind of get off on
something cuz we watch stupid YouTube
stuff all the time but in the first
episode of Rick and Morty since I never
saw gravity falls there's a part where
one of the guys has a notebook of coffee
cup and a pencil that gets dropped into
a portal mmm I guess and then in Rick
and Marty Rick shoots a whole bunch of
portals open and as he's jumping through
all of a sudden a a mug a pen and a
notebook quickly pop out of it
oh like you want the gravity falls
episodes they do then they nurse it
through some portal or whatever I guess
oh my god I don't even know and gravity
falls is one of those kind of like
Adventure Time and Steven universe like
there's also clues and hints going on
throughout the whole thing and stuff so
that's that's really funny oh yeah so I
know there's a connection there with
Adventure Time
I don't think there's as much of a
connection I just know that like Katy
chips I know her actually from first
from Malcolm in the Middle where she was
on an episode just one episode the one
where they're doing the prom like that's
all I remember her and then yeah from CD
from wow I was gonna say gravity this
stupid universe so that I think is
pretty cool there's another Steven
universe connection but for me the
episodes kind of like be careful what
you get rid of you may not actually want
to get rid of it hmm you know in someone
may annoy you or something they bother
you and then you get rid of a Nelson
it's like oh crap what did I do
hmm you know that's kind of more or less
what I saw from this but then again I
think if it's annoying you should get
rid of it I will say this the fact
they're gonna get rid of me are ya I
trust me up here you've been gone a long
time
but in terms of what makes a little bit
more interesting more I think about you
know now that you brought that up is
that if they Larry just said chips and
ice cream the same way the whole time
then you'd be like well this is like you
know Stockholm or he's just not to drove
him nuts or whatever but because you
know they're communicating and there's
different inflections and stuff there is
a little bit more of an opportunity for
him to make a connection with them even
though he has no idea what they're
saying so because there is definitely
inflections and they cry and they get
happy and they say and stuff like that
so there's definitely personalities
there you just don't know how they're
you know what they're saying
yeah so I think that at least allows a
little bit more of a reason why there
could be a connection you know why he
wouldn't want to get away from him
necessarily or he didn't think that he
would also going back to family like you
said you've been with him for so long
love them or hate them there's still
part of you in a sense I thought was
interesting but then again about
something saying chips and ice cream
over and over and my freaking head
scissors or something and no I probably
want to do what be Moser I would try to
figure out how to communicate that be
the fruit cuz clearly they have
inflections and you know cab
personalities and stuff a that would be
the first day of my okay I gotta gotta
be able to communicate with these things
somehow I'd be doing what BMO was doing
and then cut them off and say never come
back um taco burrito taco burrito taco
burrito burrito taco taco taco taco taco
taco taco Berea done